[Music]
thank you
questions
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
happy decent [__] wage day
that's right it is Labor Day
you are joining me here live
September 4th
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter Facebook and twitch
that's right we're live today on Labor
Day hey look these Nazis aren't gonna
sleep why should I that's the way I
figure it happy decent [__] wage day
now for me to you
um I I did a patreon last night we
opened it up to a public it's got
thousands of views a lot of people saw
me uh smash the Nazis last night if you
haven't seen it you need to go watch
this uh
extended version of me
hypothetically you know punching Nazis
you should go you should go launch it
just hit the hit the Subscribe button
here on YouTube you'll find that uh
video under the live section also you
gotta check out the shorts that we've
been producing
skip over on Discord speaking of Discord
and skip over on Discord thank you uh to
skip for doing all the edits over there
you guys should go check out his YouTube
channel as well just go to the Discord
and type in Skip's name he'll uh he'll
get you to the correct spot
that's right the Discord is open today
they're having fun over there today it's
where the chat party never stops
honestly I'm gonna do a lot of um since
it's Labor Day I'm gonna do a lot of
self-promotion today if you don't mind
oh don't worry we're gonna pepper in
we're gonna pepper in punch in some
Nazis Marjorie Taylor green did you know
Alex Jones is a Fed I don't know I
didn't know that I didn't know that
maybe he is I'm gonna play you a couple
interviews that Alex Jones has done on
Infowars uh people who hate the feds
it's almost like Alex Jones is a fit
maybe stodger Roan is a fed too I don't
know I surmised that I think last week
I surmise maybe those two are feds
they're the right Wingers are out
blaming the Nazis that they're feds
though you know feds that's what they do
they go get Nazi tattoos and [__] on
their faces just so you know it's
authentic right get the [__] out of here
people are dumb as dog [__]
these not these DeSantis Nazis
supporters down there in Florida are
feds you people are blind as a bat
if you think that these [__] idiots
down in Florida are feds and not Nazis
okay it's really kind of ridiculous but
it is the right wing it is it is
Republicans what are you going to do in
this day and age besides mock them and
make fun of them
and I I you know I think there's there's
a chance that Alex Jones is a Fed
I'll point it out to you I'll show you
what I mean as the show goes along so
don't go anywhere today back to the
self-promotion if I may
you know we are an independent show here
we we run on your support that is right
it's kind of like uh you remember the
old PBS NPR they're like we're funded
from viewers like you that's literally
what we are we are funded from viewers
like you and last night we did a new
thing on the patreon everyone knows that
I love Jager Bombs and I love
Jagermeister and I love to do Jaeger
shots whether it's in bomb vorm or just
straight Jaeger I seriously that's how I
drink at a bar
my friends can attest to how many Jager
shots that they bought for me
and last night we had several people buy
me digital shots they're digital shots
but it is that Maria uh Yvonne Robert
and then Robin bought a round for
everyone that's right Robin F bought a
round for everyone last night after the
show had ended
so thank you Robin F if you're out there
listening for buying a round for
everyone so today on this Labor Day
since Robin bought us all around I want
to show you where you can go buy a shot
and where you can take your shot if you
go to the Tony michaels.com first thing
is subscribe up here at the top note for
hit forget to hit the Subscribe button
You're Not Gonna Wanna Go
without hitting the Subscribe button
because any changes that are made I'm
now notifying you on the website so you
guys know like the link to Today's Show
I sent I sent all the subscribers an
email
saying hey the the link has changed you
guys should go watch the show so if you
don't want to miss an episode if you
don't want to miss a change on the
website make sure to go do that you can
see here's where you can buy a shot and
you can buy a shot of Jaeger a double
shot or you can buy a round for everyone
so thank you for Robin f for buying
everyone around so if you're out there
right now
and you're celebrating Labor Day and
you're celebrating with shots Robin
bought us all around
so hold your shot glasses up and thank
Robin for buying around because really
it's your guys's support that keeps this
show going
it really is
um your
uh
we enjoy enjoy your double shot Tony hey
I'll I'll do double shots triple shots
I'll do all the shots and trust me some
of the money that you actually put into
the buy Tony shop will go
to alcohol for sure no question it'll
end up being shots eventually
so if you want if you want to support
the show and I appreciate all your
guys's support no matter how much of a
joke it really is you can go buy a shot
you can do a venmo super chat if you do
a venmo super Channel actually pull the
message up on air make sure that you uh
put your hand on what
what platform you're on so I can bring
that up to another way to support the
show and me is to support me on on
patreon uh and you go right here again
just the Tony michaels.com hit subscribe
at the top you're not gonna that's free
it doesn't cost you anything to
subscribe and then follow us everywhere
and if you can
do shots yeah someone in the disc or
Tony TB is saying shots during karaoke
if you buy me a shot when we do the
patreon karaoke which I think we're
going to start next month
um we're gonna do a a Sunday or two a
month with the karaoke where everyone
can watch and everyone can buy me a shot
I will actually do the shot live on air
because we'll be on Twitch
so we won't have to you know go by
YouTube's rules where I can't like smoke
and
and take uh take shots oh mighty
librarian is saying that we have Tony
and Gabe emojis over on Discord are you
serious
uh-oh rat row
there's Gabe and and [__] em emojis oh
my God we're in trouble over there so if
you if you want to get in on the Discord
again go to the Tony michaels.com pan
down uh you'll see the Discord server
there uh also if you click on the smash
the flash art contest you'll be able to
get to the Discord from there make sure
you're verifying when you enter the
Discord so you so you don't have to
re-enter it's very simple to verify it's
not that hard if you need directions
just go to the Welcome Center or get
with Mighty librarian she'll she'll show
you how to she'll show you how to verify
over there so just get verified that way
you can get into the live show chat
they're they're you're going nuts uh
with the Gabe and Tony emojis
unfortunately Gabe Sanchez is not going
to join us today he's he's taking the
day off I'm sure he's making content
he's probably doing a what was that but
um
he was he was gonna take the day off
from the show here so that way we can
we can say he got Labor Day off oh my
God they're with the [__] I'm Lo but the
[__] emojis in them and the stuff
over there like crazy they're going
crazy over there so get in on the
Discord as well again it's where the
chat party never stops that thing goes
24 7. there's people in it all night
long I put the link in the chat there if
you want to go do the Discord also if
you want to do a a venmo chat here's the
um here's the link to that to the venmo
if you guys want to get in on a venmo
chat if you want me to post your comment
on it's kind of like I can't do like
Collins and I mean like guest calls but
it's a way for you guys to get your
message on the screen if you want to go
do a venmo super chat because I don't do
YouTube super chats because they [__]
hate my guts they won't let me monetize
because of the [__] I say what are you
gonna do
but I'm I'm funded I'm funded from
viewers like you
works out really good actually because
then no one can tell me what the hell to
say right no one can tell me what the
hell to say or what not to say I'm not
I'm not owned by anyone and this is an
independent show and we remain
independent and we will keep saying the
f word loudly and proudly so I'm glad
you're joining us today uh for this uh
Labor Day
are in other words in other words
decent [__] wage day also that
they're posting the [__] em logo in the
uh in the Discord like crazy did you
guys know you can get it as a sticker
and there's a pride one too we usually
put it on at the end of the show but
here let me show you what we're talking
about why we're doing cell promotion why
not right we're doing so promotion might
as well here's a picture of the the
pride [__] em uh logo or you can get the
original the OG like it is here on the
sticker here
or you get a [__] em hat just go to the
Tony michaels.com that's the
tonymichaels.com you can find those
there the merch stores there also visit
Gabe's merch store as well
get you get you some [__] them stickers
some [__] a merch go get you a pardon
blanket over there if you can thank you
for joining us
today on the Tony Michaels podcast like
I said I'm going to show some videos of
these uh these Nazis but if you want my
extended version or my extended rant
um you can go to
you can go to the uh the patreon Sunday
rant last night it is public it's up on
YouTube you can find it there
maybe I should make a playlist of all
the public patreon stuff I don't know I
don't know maybe maybe we'll just do
that
um we're gonna have I think we're gonna
have Fred Wellman on tomorrow and of
course Texas Paul as well uh tomorrow
I'm trying to get Tennessee Brando back
sometime this week so hopefully he can
arrange a time this week that we can do
that so just a little more laid back
today here on the Tony Michaels podcast
since it is decent [__] wage Day and
Labor Day we're celebrating uh unions
you know it's kind of funny uh I don't
mention Joe Biden's name a lot on this
show but since it's Labor Day you know I
might as well give him some credit here
I never give him enough credit probably
for what he's doing I I have to spend so
much time fighting the right wing here
on the Tony Michaels podcast I don't
have time
to prop him up
um everyone's bringing up that
Boston Brian is in the YouTube chat
Boston Brian's here in the YouTube chat
of of a fan favorite well you should get
Brian back on now I was talking to him
and we should have him back on at some
point I think we should do that what do
you think Brian
we've had Boston Bryant on once once I
think once should get him back on but
we're gonna have Texas Paul this week I
think Fred Wellman's gonna come on uh
tomorrow
and and hopefully we'll get Tennessee
Brando sometime this week we need to
have Dr Rachel bittickoffer on again too
it's been a while hasn't it maybe she
should come on and smash some Nazi smash
the fash
as we say
um here on the Tony Michaels podcast uh
what was I talking about before that oh
yes Joe Biden see I lose track
Joe Biden is the most pro-union
president that we have had in modern
times
um and not only is he for the union for
the sake of being four unions and you
know he does he does hail from a card
carrying heavy card carrying Union car
caring part of the country
from Scranton Pennsylvania but the thing
is is that he is pro uh labor he's Pro
for the American people negotiating
their labor and getting a decent [__]
wage
um that is the that is the point
being for the unions you don't actually
have to be a union member to be like hey
hey uh it's a good idea for people to
get paid what they're worth oh my God
isn't that just a novel idea
how radical of people how radical of
these Americans to think that they get
paid what they're worth for crying out
loud right they get paid a decent
[__] wage for A Hard Day's Work come
on man that's a radical idea no one in
the history of ever has ever thought
about that give me a [__] break
give me a [__] break this isn't hard
really and really honestly it's not hard
for a president of the United States
whether it's Joe Biden or anyone else
to be four people getting a decent
[__] wait what do you think drives
the economy
why do why do you think the economy that
we have is the economy that we have
I mean a lot of people are worried about
inflation
but folks people who've had a decent
wage for a long time who are union
members who have fought for their wages
and some some union members you know
it's been a long time since they've
negotiated so they they're under that
decent [__] wage level now we saw
that with ups and the part-time and
full-timers now they came to an
agreement The Writer's strike and sag
strike still isn't over and I think
there's going to be more strikes to come
in this country it's because Koba taught
us that right
in 2020 when when the nation was like oh
my God we're gonna die if we get a virus
but all you essential workers
essential workers need to stay working
and everyone kind of looked around like
whoa It's the lowest paid workers that
are essential
like what the [__] well that ain't right
we really taught ourselves something
during that time didn't we
and we taught ourselves that you know we
shouldn't be thanking corporations and
businesses for the favors that they do
us by giving us a job [__] that [__]
[__] that [__]
they should be thanking us for the work
we do for them to make their profits
[__] them and that's the way it should
be viewed
right
you know capitalism isn't all bad I know
a lot of people on the left want to act
like capitalism is the end of the world
folks we've had capitalism for a long
time in this country and they're like oh
it's the end times of capitalism in
stage capitalism get the [__] out of
here it's not it's not the end of
capitalism
it's that capitalism takes and the
[__] richest people in this country
take the most of the GDP
okay
they're taking the majority of the GDP
just a handful of [__] imagine
imagine uh how people would feel about
capitalism if the majority of the GDP
went to the majority of the workers
went to the majority of the people who
worked their [__] ass off every
goddamn day of the week huh
what then what then may say you
because I I know it feels good to act
like capitalism all bad right oh yeah it
feels good for a lefty to say that
feels good and some capitalism is
[__] awful like when there's a profit
motive for People's Health in this
country [__] that [__] no one should go
broke because of a medical bill nobody
nobody and we shouldn't be profiting off
people having [__] medical conditions
in this country are trying to stay alive
because of a medical condition in this
country I don't care who force fed them
the fudge bags of fudge rounds Oliver
Anthony you [__] fat phobic
[__]
but that's the rub that's the rub and
that's the difference between maybe the
messaging of the democratic party
getting their [__] together and the
Republicans not knowing their [__]
head from their ass
because they don't
and Democrats better get their [__]
together they better get their messaging
together they better leave behind all
these [__] media Elites all these
people highbrow [__] that think
they can tell us the normal average
American working people how the [__]
we're gonna talk about issues and how
we're going to feel about them
you know with their [__] data and
their stupid dumb ass lying ass polls oh
pole says this poll says that a poll
says this well what [__] do you
know who's taking a poll and what
[__] do you know who has ever
believed a poll huh
do you believe polls do you I don't I
don't believe a single [__] one of
them even if they're right even if it
feels good to me like oh man that poll
looks good it it confirms my bias
I don't believe that [__]
we shouldn't
we shouldn't believe what the hell the
the [__] hierarchy is telling us to
believe
we know better than that
that's why that's why we need to focus
on us as America
on this Labor Day and what it means to
us
we don't have to listen to Marjorie
Taylor green drone on about out of a
deep State and the feds have devised
some plan to flood the burning man I'm
dead serious I'm gonna show you this
[__] tape from imp Awards Marjorie
Taylor green went on Infowars and said
the Deep state in the feds flooded the
[__] Lake
in Nevada so that that way burning man
could uh convince people at Burning Man
that climate change is real or some [__]
like what the [__] get the hell out of
here with that nonsense
who the [__] believes this [__] Jesus
Christ if you think if you think that
the feds in the Deep State flooded
Burning Man to convince people of
climate change
I've I've got a 91 felony count indicted
former president that I'll sell you to
be our great leader seems kind of weird
that it's the same [__] that
believe this [__] about the feds and
deep state are in on burning man that
are going to go vote for Trump didn't it
seem a little weird to you doesn't it
come on give me a [__] break
but I'm going to show you that clip oh
my God it's something else and then I'm
going to show you the the clip of Joe
Biggs oh my God oh my God this guy cried
in court he begged the judge this proud
boy
please please I want to see my daughter
well maybe if you gave a [__] more about
your daughter than you did about
overthrowing our government
in the name of King Trump maybe if you'd
have thought about it a little more you
would have you would have been her daddy
and you would have watched her grow up
and walk her down the aisle and watch
her graduate and [__] and take her to
school quit your [__] crying you
whiny little [__] I thought these are
supposed to be [__] tough guys seems
like these proud boys are [__]
snowflakes done that to you and then the
[__] then the [__] when
the judge leaves the courtroom he says
Trump won the [__] out of here and then
he calls into Alex Jones and whines and
cries to him get the [__] out of here
man up [__]
do your time just like all the rest of
us you [__] [__] what a [__] what
a goddamn [__]
look I've been in that position before I
didn't [__] cry in court that's right
I didn't
oh please save me please save me
actually frankly I was pissed off at the
judge because he said some outright lies
but that's fine whatever he wanted to do
he's a federal judge but I didn't cry I
got pissed off I was really [__]
pissed off oh man I was [__] hot I
was mad I ain't crying you [__] [__]
what are you crying about
[__] you crying about you goddamn [__]
get over it you did the crime do the
time now I mean who cares Joe Biggs your
[__] Almighty Jesus Mussolini Jesus
your orange Mussolini Jesus is oh man
he's gonna be president again he's gonna
pardon you and himself or some [__] the
[__] out of here
you you
[__]
what a goddamn [__]
these proud boys are
but you know that's how it goes that's
how the fast go
uh just like these uh Nazis these the
Santa supporters that showed up at Walt
Disney World and ended up on an overpass
and I don't know what what is the
significance of the overpass that they
were on is there a significance to it I
never really thought about that until
just now you know what I mean how do
they pick out these overpasses that
they're going to be Nazis on
are they like oh that one's a lit oh man
well that's a lift guard overpass on
that libtard Highway let's go be Nazis
there I don't know why do they pick
these out is there a certain reason is
there something that I'm [__] missing
here I don't know I mean I know why they
go protest drag shoes
because he some of these Nazis that
showed up uh in Florida over the weekend
uh that were oh man they're huge
DeSantis fans they [__] love I wonder
I wonder what it is about the neo-nazis
liking Governor Ron weirdo DeSantis hmm
spaghetti and meatball I don't know
maybe it's a thing
uh joyly says on on Discord it's so
people driving will see them yeah I know
but like why that specific overpass is
there something about that one like is
it like oh that one's obvious I mean
it's on the same Highway there's got to
be more overpasses on that Highway where
there's a lot of traffic I don't know it
just seemed like a really dumb one to
pick because there's a big fence so no
one jumps off the bridge which you know
when the Nazis are on the bridge maybe
they should take the fence down just
saying I'm just saying don't get after
me who wouldn't like to see a few Nazis
you know end up as [__] splatters on
the highway from the overpass I'm just
saying this is how we did it in 1940
and these Nazis that showed up on this
overpass with this weird fence with all
these letters to where you couldn't
really see him unless you were going
across the overpass not on the highway
underneath here's the thing here's a
weird thing about all this
is that these
putting people in ovens
on the overpass like yelling and
screaming putting people in ovens
but they're like we're not violent
you're the ones who are violent you're
the ones who want to stop us well see we
did that [__]
we did that [__] in 1940.
and really honestly you know if they
don't stop this [__] the Republican
Party the Republican Party better stop
their nonsense
and they better get in and check and
they better realize that these Nazis
showing up at Disney World and on
overpasses in Florida supporting Ron
DeSantis aren't just [__] little you
know happen stances no
this is because of their rhetoric and
because of their ideology their fascist
you're [__] fascist have you seen
what the superintendent of schools is
doing down in Oklahoma you don't have to
go very far in any state to look and see
a [__] Nazi you just don't have to
Jesus Christ here in Missouri you should
hear some of the [__] they say on the
[__] house floor and the senate floor
here in Missouri go to Tennessee and
look what Cameron Sexton is doing down
there
then Tennessee how he's trying to
subvert democracy and you'll realize
that fascists are [__] everywhere and
it seems to be that the the people who
are fashion the most are [__]
Republicans
seems like that's why the neo-nazis are
in support of them and their agenda I
wonder what it could be about Ron
DeSantis
maybe that he wants to be the next Adolf
Hitler
he's the authoritarian Android the
Florida fascist meatball pudding fingers
Ron DeSantis
[__] piece of [__] but that's the
thing
that's the thing because they'll just
scoff it off the right Wing's like oh
all them Nazis down there in Florida
they're feds
their feds they totally got all them
Nazi tattoos and they got all nazied up
just to trick America she to make us the
The
Not So avert Nazis look bad
get the [__] out of here man
get the [__] out of here there's no one
pretending to be Nazis just to make the
other Nazis look bad that's not a thing
they're just Nazis
that's it and you know algorithms don't
like the word Nazi they don't that's
that's why you one reason why YouTube
doesn't like me it's one reason why Tick
Tock doesn't like me that's one reason
why Facebook doesn't like me is because
I say the word Nazi and I direct it in a
way to call the actual Nazis Nazis
not some sort of historical context or
be like well in 1942 the Nazis marched
now
cold hard facts and if you don't like it
I don't know what the [__] to tell you
stop being a Nazi
if you don't want to be called that [__]
these same Nazis
that showed up on this overpass they're
the same ones that went to Ohio
and protested drag shows and we're
spewing Republican policy talking points
at the people at the drag show from
their bullhorns
you [__]
and you act like you act like I'm the
bad guy for calling Republicans Nazis
Republicans are trying to Institute in
law what these people are yelling and
screaming out of bullhorns at their Nazi
rallies I don't know what to tell you
it's not my [__] fault
how is it my fault that this [__] is
happening and I just have to point it
out
now some would say well Tony you could
point it out in a certain way no you
can't no you can't
you can't go like glove with these
[__]
you have to give them everything you got
when you listen
if you're gonna hypothetically punch a
Nazi right the hypothetically speaking
because we're not talking about violence
here
look
if you're going to hypothetically punch
a Nazi are you gonna you know hold back
are you gonna throw everything you got
into that [__] huh what are you
gonna do
in 1940 in 19 in the 1940s we gave it
all we got
and it took a long time to beat back the
German Nazis a long time to beat back
Hitler in the German Nazis years
it took to put them in their place but
fascism always ends this way and the
reason why fascism always ends this way
is because it seems like a populist
message at first
but then when there's no one left to
help you when they come for you people
start to catch on
oh oh so you're not gonna stop until
you're the only one that has power and
you're the only one that can dictate
policy it's almost like it's a
dictatorship an authoritarian hmm seems
kind of weird
but that's what these people want
that's what they crave they crave
authoritarianism
they crave to tell you what the [__] you
can and cannot do
who you can marry who you can love what
books you can [__] read what songs
you can listen to how you can dress
rather a woman can have a job rather a
woman can vote whether a woman can get
[__] health care at all
they want to be able to tell you all
that [__] and for anyone to say that
well that's not fascism that's just our
religion well I'm sorry that you worship
Nazis
that's not my [__] problem that ain't
what it says in the second half of the
book that you claim to believe
white Christian nationalists are not
Christians they just claim to be just
like Nazis weren't socialists they just
claimed to be
and if you don't like what I'm saying
and you don't like when I call white
people Nazis if you don't like that if
it really hurts your feels then I'm
talking to you
that's right if you get mad that I call
White Christian nationalist Nazis if I
call Republicans Nazis if it pisses you
off and it gets you really [__] fired
up inside and hating me I'm talking to
you
laugh
so get with it
you [__] pieces of [__]
get with it Republicans
come to grips with it they're not feds
they're Nazis and so are you
Ron DeSantis Donald Trump Marjorie
Taylor green
and the rest of their ilk may not think
they're Nazis okay you may not think
you're a Nazi but the neo-nazis think
you're a Nazi and that's good enough for
me to know that you're a Nazi don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show welcome welcome
back
[Music]
chat come in if you want to get on the
venmo chat if you want your message to
appear on screen here on the Johnny
Michaels but guess go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you'll see the venmo chat
at the very top of the page or you can
buy me a shot if you want to buy around
for me or a double shot or if you want
to buy a round for everyone get in on
the shots trust me that money will go
towards Jagermeister at some point but
if you want to give a venmo Super Chat
go to the Tony michaels.com Boom the
link is right there and get a venmo chat
um Pace sent this message said Tony if
every man was like you this country
would be a [__] Utopia thank you for
being a great guy look I'm not just
trying to be a great guy I'm just trying
to defend what what I want my children
my children's children to have is the
institution of democracy
you know I I might be on the right side
of History here I believe that
but it's more about than just than just
me
it's about what I was afforded what was
given before me even is thinking about
this Labor Day think about the people
who have lost their lives in this
country there are people who lost their
lives in this country to fight for the
right to negotiate their [__] pay
lost their lives think about the people
who fought for our freedom
think about for the people who fought
against fascism in the 1930s and the
1940s
to make sure that fascism didn't spread
around the world
think about that
those people who returned home
and the white folk in this country who
were afforded every [__] every
[__] privilege that they possibly
could in this country after the second
world war to make the white middle class
the white middle class and Left Behind
the minorities in this country
and we still work today to try to bring
that level of equality inequity to a
position where everyone in this country
I don't care who you are what religion
what gender what what where you come
from what your experience is rather
you're you were born here or weren't
born here rather you're a natural
citizen or or you become a citizen or
you're a non-citizen everyone should be
able
everyone should be able to get a fair
Shake in this country and have that the
amount of equity and equality that is
deserved to every human [__] being
and the harder we fight for that
with our messaging and our narrative the
more we'll win because folks we are at
War they're like ah it's a civil war
it's a civil war no the Civil War is in
your party okay that's the Civil War
that you're having the war we got going
on is a war of information
and who's gonna brainwash who
and it's full on war all I'm here is for
the general of the truth that's all I am
is just the general of the truth and to
give it to you the way that Patton gave
his troops
cold
and with facts
not with data and all the [__] and
all the extras
served cold and raw
that is what this is intent of this show
is
and I appreciate the support Pace as
always with the venmo chat and thank you
for your kind words thank you very much
for your kind words and being here lets
me know
lets me know that you believe in the
level of equality and diversity and
Equity that every human should be
afforded in this country that we claim
to be free and we claim that we want
Liberty
and our freedom and our rights will
deliver us that if we believe in the
institutions of democracy and we stand
on those principles
and continue to stand on those liberal
principles that's right I said it
liberal principles the strength of
Freedom the strength of Liberty is
liberal principles I don't care what the
rights is and I don't care what the far
left says because they're like oh
liberals bad lib lib libbys Libby's
libbies we're liberal [__] because
we're for freedom
so thank you for your kind words there
again if you want to get in on the venmo
chat go to the Johnny michaels.com I'll
keep an eye on it during the show here
if you want to get in on the vent mode
chat and if you want if you want me to
give you a shout out for your handle on
on whatever platform make sure to
include the platform and your handle in
your message otherwise I just kind of go
off your name but I don't say your whole
name out loud
I won't say your whole name out loud
but if you put your handle and the
platform that you're on I'll say that
for the shout out so thank you for all
the support you guys are the best in the
world you really are and it means so
much to me because without you I
couldn't do this every day I know it
seems weird to like go to a website and
buy Tony a shot right or send a venmo
chat or support on patreon sometimes it
feels weird to do that if you if you can
do that though it keeps me going it
keeps me yelling and screaming it keeps
me pumping the narrative
and I know sometimes it seems like well
what's the point because we're up
against so much and so it's so big
but trust me we can do it I'm telling
you and MJ will tell you this the great
moderator MJ will tell you this she was
OG her and Margie both
they were here when there was like three
people listening one of them was being
one of them was MJ I'm not kidding you
there's like three maybe four less than
a dozen [__] we're listening
and now we get thousands every single
day listening to this show and I believe
we'll get tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands by the time we get to the
election next year and the reason why is
they can't stop us
they can't stop us if we if if we do
this together and you keep me yelling
and screaming to this microphone on a
daily basis two hours a day we want to
go to three hours a day and we're we're
trying to figure out a way to do that as
soon as we can we really are trying to
figure out a way to get to three hours a
day
we really are
so just just keep supporting keep
watching keep sharing keep sharing
the links keep sharing that just the
message
and if you can pitch in help us out oh
the other thing too I know the audience
wants me and Gabe to meet live and in
person and me and him have been talking
about the DNC in Chicago next year and I
think we're going to do some planning
with the audience here I think we're
going to try to do some planning so
we're going to try to get the three
hours we're trying to think about how to
do that and we're gonna try to figure
out a way that we can give you content
of me and Gabe meeting would you guys
like that wouldn't that be wouldn't that
be killer
because we have never met in person did
you know that we've never I have never
met Gabe Sanchez in person and he's
never met me in person I think it would
be kind of cool if we did something next
summer if we meet
if we meet
um at the DNC if we did content around
that I think that would be really cool
I think it would be awesome uh or not
not just not just uh for us but for you
guys to see that because you guys have
been here the whole time like I'm
serious when me and Gabe when me and
Gabe were first when he first came on
the show I think it was like uh
anyways like
really honestly I think we had like
maybe I don't know MJ probably knows
this she remembers so much because she's
been here since the beginning but uh and
Margie too and a lot of the the
moderators here but they probably
remember when we had like you know we
were getting like a hundred views
like on our episodes on YouTube
like a hundred people right
and some of you are still the 100 ogs
and I appreciate you every single day it
means so much that you're still here and
you listen to the show from the front to
the back every single day even on a
labor day you guys look how many people
are here there's like there's like 1300
people here today
on Labor Day
1300 people
on of holiday
that's [__] awesome that means a lot
to me do you know how much that means to
me
that you guys came to listen to me on
your holiday for two hours me yapping
yapping to the microphone
and and and give you appreciation and
and get you guys to to support us that
means the world to me
and and I I know I know us being here
every day
means the world to you I get messages
every day just just like just like Pace
set I get messages like that every day
and it's what keeps us going so keep us
going let's talk more later on about
what we're gonna do in Chicago how we're
gonna meet what kind of content you guys
want because I'm serious I would love
remember when we had the uh um the
wiener Circle ah my forgetting her name
right off hand I should remember her
name but the wiener Circle came on and
talked about how Ed Sheeran came to
Weiner and they she said there's a
podcaster in there how [__] cool
would it be
how [__] cool would it be if we
broadcast it from that room every day
that week at the DNC that would be
pretty [__] cool I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna lie and I think I think
with your guys's help we can make that
all possible and we would we would love
to show you guys that content and and
footage from when we first meet and I'd
love to meet some of you guys oh my God
I'd love to meet somebody real life in
person belly to belly eating a [__]
hot dog together
how awesome would that be
to eat hot dogs with Gabe Sanchez the
guy with the last name Sanchez said be
awesome it would be awesome
so let's uh let's figure out a way we
can do that
um
let's see
okay let's see what oh oh I should
probably do the show now in a hot
Jerry said in a hot tub I mean do you
want hot tub content is that what you
want I mean I'm not I'm not opposed to
doing hot tub content you know what I
mean
uh but we might have to gate the hot tub
content I'm just saying you know
how many days has it been since we
talked about porn on here oh man maybe
our counter will get to zero today oh my
God you should see the hot tub and hot
tub and hot dog
content on Discord and Jesus [__]
Christ you people over there they need
Jesus over there on the Discord
get in on the jet on Discord it's the
best of the best of the [__] fam and
they have Gabe and Tony emojis over
there
um
and they got hot dog and hot tub gifts
over there as well so get get it going
get it going
oh let's see what else what else are we
are we doing today
oh we might as well get to some clips
[__] it I want to show you this uh
Marjorie take these info work clips of
Alex Jones and I want to explain to you
why I think Alex Jones is probably a fit
I don't I mean I don't know for sure I
don't know these things for sure it's
just evidence that I've gathered up
from what the hell is going on
I mean you know what I mean I think
stodger Roan is too you know stagger Ron
is otherwise known as Roger Stone I
think that guy's a fit
[__] yeah he's a fit here let's let's
start let's start with how I think
ronder stone is
okay I'm gonna have to go way back in my
timeline here to find this video but
someone posted a video
um
on on Twitter
I think it was said at the end of the
week last week it kind of flew
underneath the radar uh but Roger Stone
it was the last day of Trump's
presidency and Roger Stone was really
looking for
like uh uh you know he's looking for a
pardon his second part and he had his
his sentence Community wanted to Pardon
they're threatening the Trump was
threatening that he wasn't going to give
a pardon and Roger Stone was really
pissed off about it
and really honestly when I watched this
video I was like holy [__] this is what
is laying in wait for Donald Trump
when we reach the Kool-Aid moment now
that's important when we talk about this
especially since we're talking about
Nazis and all kinds of other [__] like
that
the Kool-Aid Moment In The Cult you know
what I'm talking about
you know I'm talking about the Kool-Aid
moment the Kool-Aid moment is like when
Jim Jones asked his followers to drink
the Kool-Aid
and they drink the Kool-Aid and kill
themselves and he and he then he shot
himself he he didn't have enough guts to
drink the Kool-Aid himself
but when we we're gonna reach a point in
the manga cult where they have a
Kool-Aid moment I mean you know that
right
we're gonna get to a point to where
there is a Kool-Aid moment if I can find
this clip of Roger Stone Jesus Christ is
it really that far back on the timeline
was it that long ago I didn't think it
was surely it wasn't no I can't be I'll
find it here hang on
um
but Roger Stone was in the back seat of
a of a of an SUV
and I'm not sure exactly where he was
going but he was [__] Jack jaldin
losing his mind
about
Trump
and getting where the [__] is this clip
God damn it I thought I had it maybe
someone erased it and deleted it surely
it's somewhere on here but he's in the
back seat of an SUV and he's Jack Jordan
he's talking about how he's going to
seek retribution on Trump
and he's gonna back impeachment if Trump
doesn't [__] do what he wants which
is to give him a pardon how in the [__]
is this video not where I want it to be
uh no that's not the one someone's
sending me one of them in a hotel it's
in where he's in the back seat of a car
if you can find it drop it in the um
drop it in the Discord I'm watching the
Discord
I can see it but he's all Jack jawed and
[__] what the [__] where did they take
this video down from Twitter
is that what happened
are you [__] serious
yes they did
and it was a report from the copyright
owner are you [__] [__] me
holy [__] [__] that is I'm serious
that's real they took that [__] down
because of the copyright
what the [__]
all right
I'm gonna have to find this video and
post to say yeah here it is [__] it I
got it I got it not it's it's not the
exact one that I want but
um
maybe I can find a better version here
I'm gonna play it I don't give a [__]
come after me [__] with your
copyright [__]
that's some [__]
no there it is okay well this isn't the
best version but it's the version that
we got here let me see if I can pull it
up on screen holy [__] did you guys know
that
that's crazy [__] okay so here is um
here's a video of some sort of Roger
Stone in the max Eva car after he finds
out that Donald Trump is not planning on
pardoning him listen to what he says and
more importantly if you can see it
listen watch his Jack jawness
yeah how can they do that
right right
you don't understand people I do Rod
should hold a press conference today and
call for Trump's impeachment that's what
I would do that's what I would do I'm
gonna do it I'm I'm a supporting
impeachment I'm supporting impeachment
he must be removed his son Jared must be
prosecuted
I want to know how many changed hands
I've been and I want a federal
investigation I'm finally complaint with
the FBI this afternoon
of these people of these people
right right so right
right exactly which is which is why I'm
for the impeachment I want impeachment
I'm gonna work very hard for it
I'm not kidding
it'd be in betrayed Bernie betrayed Rudy
to everybody so he knows to God he has
to go
run again you get your [__] your [__]
brains Beat It
right
right which is good unfortunately for
Pat because she's easy
[__] this paintball
let's be very clear let's be very clear
there is no vet in [__] it's one
sentence one sentence so if you're
intermediate and he says that you punch
him in the mouth as hard as you can to
make your point it's one sentence we're
not stupid there is no paperwork you
[__] he needs to be impeached
it needs to be denounced and impeached
the greatest single mistake in American
history greatest single mistake we're
surrounded by morons and he surrounded
himself by morons and a good long
sentence in prison he'll give him a
chance to think about it
the southern districts come in foreign
[Music]
oh
I you know I don't know where the the
abortionist thing comes from I guess
because Ivanka at once claimed that she
was pro-life I guess I don't know I
don't know but this is again he's all
Jack child he's all riled up about not
getting a pardon and he's talking about
Trump here folks
and this is what is laying in weight
for Donald Trump
this is what is laying in weight
when the Kool-Aid moment comes now what
I what do I mean by that now this is
what leads me to believe that Roger
Stone's a Fed but we're going to go down
this Kool-Aid moment road first then
we'll go back to the being a Fed
now
the Kool-Aid moment is what happens to
Jim Jones at Jonestown when he realizes
he realizes oh my God
I'm going to be exposed as being a fraud
and my cult is gonna know I'm a fraud
so I'm gonna kill them all and kill
myself
and I'm going to ask them to kill
themselves the the Kool-Aid moment as it
were right now there's gonna be a
Kool-Aid moment in Maga there's gonna be
I'm not sure what it looks like I'm not
sure what it is I have no idea I don't
know if that Kool-Aid moment is a year
from now two years from now 10 years
from now I have no idea I don't know
when that's gonna happen
but when the Kool-Aid moment comes
this is what is laying in weight people
like Roger Stone who knows Trump's a
fraud Rudy Giuliani Marjorie Taylor
green Jim Jordan Kevin McCarthy
all these [__] people who capitulate
to him call the Republicans that
capitulate to his nonsense into his cult
they're all coming from him for him and
this is what is laying in weight now to
the FED part
if you if you think that Roger Stone
isn't some sort of federal informant
you're a [__] bonehead
you're a bonehead if he's gonna turn on
his God his Jesus because he won't do
what he wants him to do are you kidding
me
and you're saying you're saying that you
think that Roger Stone isn't a Fed how
in the [__] is it that Roger Stone and
Alex Jones are big buddies oh my God
they're big buddies Roger Stone is on
Alex Jones infowar all the time
all the time
but think about this for a second think
about this for a second
why isn't Roger Stone and Alex Jones
part of any of these indictments
and their name doesn't appear to be
anywhere near indicting them as a
co-conspirator why is that
it's kind of strange and the reason why
it's kind of strange is because Roger
Stone and Alex Jones were being
protected on January 6 by The Oath
Keepers
and the proud boys and cheese burrow
Trump's attorney one of the architects
of the January 6 Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup was on the ground with Alex Jones
with him in person
on January 6th Roger Stone was really
upset I believe it's in this documentary
another one he was really upset
he was very [__] upset that he didn't
get to play a part in the January 6
Insurrection and then when he found out
really what happened when people got
killed he bolted out of Washington
what is it what is it that leads me to
believe
what is it that leads me to believe this
well that's your evidence right there we
just watched Joe Biggs get his ass 17
years
we watched Stuart Rhodes the leader of
the Oath Keepers we're gonna see
tomorrow
we're gonna see
Enrique tario the leader of the of the
proud boys probably get more than 20. I
would say that I would say Enrique
agario is going to probably get the
largest sentence that we've seen of
anyone in January 6 so far
and the reason why is because Enrique
atario I don't know if you know this but
he was at the White House hmm
he was also in Washington DC with Stuart
Rhodes when he wasn't supposed to be in
Washington
and somehow some way
somehow some way
the detail
who
who is supposed to be the proud boys
protecting stodger Roan that day
got switched to The Oath Keepers seems
kind of weird and also it seems kind of
weird that Alex Jones knows Stuart
Rhodes personally
it feels like
it feels like something happened in that
parking garage when Enrique tario
and Stuart Rhodes met
um someone asked if if they know who
Stone was talking to I'm not really sure
who Stone was talking to
I'm not really sure who it is Stone is
talking to I don't know that we'll ever
know that who knows what we'll know who
knows if anyone's even on the phone
folks
who knows if anyone is even on the phone
if it's just Roger Stone talking into a
[__] phone
it's a possibility
baby now to the Alex Jones uh clips
because I want to go there I want to go
to the Joe Biggs and the Marjorie Taylor
green
um because that's the question is Alex
Jones a Fed because Alex Jones seems
entrenched in this [__] too doesn't he
it seems like he knows Joe Biggs pretty
well if Joe Biggs is calling from
federal lockup
uh on to Alex Jones's show
right it just seems like it and let me
pull the clip while I'm doing that I
think we got a guest here surprise guest
um I think is where is he from
is it is that from the East Coast Boston
I wonder how he says Coffee uh Boston
Brian how are you my friend what's up
what's happening Brother I feel like I'm
getting a lot of you today yeah I know
everyone's uh it's super excited um that
you're in the chat so I figured we'd get
you on the show if you had time so big
surprise big surprise Boston Brian is
here he rushed home to be with you here
today now have you seen this clip of
Marjorie Taylor green yet this morning
no but I did just see the one of uh
Roger Stone I'm surprised he has any
teeth left with the way he's gritting
his jar enough oh my god dude I don't
know how what what kind of drugs you
think that is you think that's Coke that
could you just be straight anger for him
why it could be it could just be the
rage have you ever seen the uh because
you can see his face get really red when
you can tell when the other person on
the phone isn't saying exactly what he
wants to be hearing well like I said
right before you came on I don't maybe
he wouldn't even talk anyone on the
phone he was just like maybe it's just
like some kind of imaginary friend but
he gets on the front like when uh what's
his face walked out of the out of the
White House and pretended to be on the
phone he could see on his phone
yeah yeah like that like that or like
Infowars where they're talking to each
other but they're really really not
talking to anybody uh either because
here's Roger Taylor green now this is
wild [__] okay so I'm surmising here
that Alex Jones is a Fed at best maybe
he's a federal informant at worst he
flips State evidence to get some of the
proud boys and The Oath Keepers we lost
Brian there oh there he is
um he probably he's probably some sort
of flipping evidence right I I would
believe Jesus Christ the guy was
entrenched in this step and there's no
way for me to believe that Alex Jones
didn't have something to do with it
especially when he was on the ground at
the Capitol on January 6th with cheese
burrow at his side in the oathkeepers
and proud boys protecting him but here
is a Marjorie Taylor green now in this
clip here's here's kind of the gist of
it I'm gonna play it but it's a it's a
pretty long clip here but she's like oh
The Burning Man stuff that's some sort
of deep State fed setup to make people
believe climate change I'm not [__]
you that's what she's saying I wouldn't
[__] you Brian you're my favorite turd
all right let's listen to Margaret
Taylor green try to give us the [__]
here thank you Alex I really appreciate
it well it's always what is the next
thing right and what we see from Marxism
what we see from the left is
ISM what what what the [__] does Burning
Man and these [__] boneheads going to
Burning Man and getting trapped in the
mud what does that have to do with
Marxism they don't know what is anyways
and by they just try to relate anything
to their buzzwords oh well do you think
they know what anything means I mean
this is a sitting United States
congresswoman and she's on Infowars with
Alex Jones
come on man this is the guy who was sued
who was sued and the parents of Newtown
won against his lies about how Newtown
was all staged and that's like a step
below Matt Gates hosting Newsmax when
you know what's his uh Greg Kelly's not
there or whatever just one step just one
step below God damn you're giving Alex
and invoice a lot of credit here but
let's let's continue to hear the
delusion uh for Marjorie Taylor green
kind of um movement that can capture the
masses get them wrapped up so they have
they put the Emoji on their their their
um on their social media so they can
share it something they get behind they
all donate their money they all get into
the movement we saw it happen with BLM
we saw okay okay before she gets into
her racism here because I Can Tell She's
gonna get into she's like I hate black
people I'm gonna show you how
um but here's the thing is that she's
describing manga to a t she's like ah
yeah just put the Emoji out there and no
don't about like just put the just put
the mug shot of the Mussolini Jesus on a
t-shirt now I'll buy it no [__]
problem they all think it's really cool
idea yeah and we can identify you right
off the bat of what we go which one's a
sucker and which one's not right right
well then which one got grifted like a
sumbitch but you know who's counting
okay let's get to her how she hates
black people because that's what she's
gonna do here with the black lives
matter stuff oh it happened with covid
math vaccines we saw what happened with
Ukraine they tried it with monkey pox we
made fun of it and it failed what what
is the monkey boxing because I believe
they thought the monkey pox
I was like what what what what who
because I never know what's going to
come out next no I because I actually
made fun of them about the monkey pox
that's I actually made fun of people who
were scared of the monkey pox I made fun
of people who were scared of the monkey
box I don't know maybe maybe I think she
used to try less weight more reps in
instead of small weight
or just trying driving the weights on
her head that might help all right let's
keep going it's time to bring covid back
but I really believe the next thing is
going to be this this climate change
crisis they're going to create it into
an emergency and Alex I want to talk
about burning man for a minute
okay before she gets into the Burning
Man
I believe most people who believe that
climate change is real have been a
little concerned about it for quite some
time this isn't like oh my God trans
people were invented yesterday and
climate change was invented today like
what the [__] are you talking about lady
this this [__] has been around for a
long time it's been around she looks
like she's she's like weight lifting to
so she can just lift the White House out
of its like Foundation one day and
remove it from the country altogether
like that's what you think she's trying
to do
have you seen your lift your senior lift
she does yes my shoulders hurt just
watching some of her exercises honestly
um you know because I I exercise myself
and I do a little bit of weightlifting I
do different than she does and the
reason why is because I don't know I
want my joints to survive when I'm you
know in my 60s or so I just I want I
want to have shoulders and knees but
listen you look really good until
everything snaps when you're doing it
her way right right well you look
fantastic I mean look at her
it's too bad all that all that CrossFit
doesn't do anything for your face that's
all I'm saying um but let's continue
here we are watching uh you know from a
distance there are approximately like 73
or 75 000 people and in Nevada and
they're locked in there from floods and
I'm glad I was going to raise that they
literally did a mock sacrifice and all
this and then it flooded with these
tornadoes and it was sorry go ahead well
it flooded with tornadoes don't you hate
when that happens I'll say that about
that but let's talk about what is
happening these people so
there's there's 70 30 75 000 people in
Nevada desert right now at this Burning
Man they're locked in they're not
allowed to leave okay that's all
[__] no one's locked in and you
build like a fence around this thing see
what happened was is it's a dry lake bed
and these stupid these stupid Rich
[__] paid a bunch of money to
go to a dry lake bed and it wasn't dry
when they got there it was actually
really [__] wet which means there's
like [__] quicksand that's why they
couldn't leave
I mean these people are getting like
these stupid [__] in in Nevada
going to Burning Man are getting like
trench foot and [__] like wow and I I'm
supposed to still feel sorry for your
damage so money they can't leave but
somehow they managed to build a whole
fence around the entire right exactly
well that's that's the Deep state for
you man it's the feds right it's the
dude right yeah right well you know that
deep mud they're getting confused and
they're basically probably being
brainwashed that climate change is the
cause of all of it
and it's going to destroy the Earth and
they're they're feeling the panic and
the media is saying that oh this is
because you didn't know about climate
change yes so what's going to happen
Alex it's the same thing same way they
launch any kind of movement after this
is over and burning man and these 75 000
people disperse and they go back home
they're going to have these stories to
tell and how terrible is and how we have
to do everything possible to stop
climate change it's caused by humans and
it's carbon okay so I don't know if
you're talking about it right good luck
if if you're trying to figure out what
she's talking about here's the thing
is if you watch the videos a little bit
of Burning Man while they're talking
these people are dancing around with
their bare feet and with trash bags over
their feet because they're getting
trench foot
um but they're having these people are
still trying to have fun in the mud
because you know FEMA's got a fence
built around the feds are keeping them
in at gunpoint I guess or something
clearly she's never been to a burning
man or ever seen one because chances are
you don't remember half the stories that
go on at Burning Man is that the point
it's in [__] Nevada what state what
happens in Nevada stays in Nevada so
she's wrong on that too right well I
mean and if you if you did enough drugs
like you were supposed to at your
burning man like you said that's what
I'm saying you won't [__] remember
[__] in the first like half those people
yeah yeah that's what I'm going to home
and I'm gonna go right to the news and
tell them about climate change
that's that's my first one of the best
things out of Burning Man and I hate I
hate this [__] all over him but Neil
katiel which I I [__] on his legal
analysis here on the show all the time
on MSN NBC that [__] got cut
caught at Burning Man and he was wearing
a ball cap with a [__] helicopter
spinner on It come on man
come on and you people get after me for
making fun of his ass and and dogging
his his legal analysis all right well
I'm sure I have to use media
personalities of freaks in some ways
that you don't know about well yeah he's
he claims it was his first time at
Burning Man and he had nothing don't
they all right right okay let's let's
finish up here with uh Marge and burning
man Alex Jones let's listen and it's the
amount of carbon that we put out it's
manufacturing it's our it's a gas and
diesel engine yep it's it's you know
agriculture it is he wants to get rid of
cattle even even population we have too
many humans this is all true this is all
true start hearing all this stuff and
this is going to build and uh yeah
because that's that's that's
all true all that [__] is true like all
you don't want to hear this and it may
sound logical and it may be factual and
backed up by data and evidence
but it's just gonna build right oh my
God you can't believe you can't believe
how hot it's gonna get either oh my God
the heat on this issue is gonna be just
[__] scorching you're gonna really
try to turn the temperature up on this
right right
I believe this is the left's new lie
they're going to put on the American
people and try to get everyone behind
and create it to where remember AOC in
the left and many others said that the
the Earth is going to literally explode
in a ball of fire we're going to all die
it's going to be the end of the world 20
30. what this is what they're bringing I
don't remember that one I I don't
remember that either I think that's a
lie what's funny is they get so close
like she's so close to the truth she's
like oh yeah it's gasoline and diesel
engines it's humans burning carbon like
she gets so close to well that's the
that's the only [__] play they have
is to give you the exact like the the
real [__] but to say it in a joking way
like Tucker Carlson used to do that all
the time he'd say the actual facts and
actually what happened but he'd say it
in a mocking manner or you know he'd
give it some sort of Voice or you know
after he said it he'd make fun of it
somehow to make it seem like that wasn't
the case you know like anybody that's
telling you that is somehow you know
bullshitting you or brainwashing you or
something like that when in actuality
that's what he's doing
right exactly exactly now I want to skip
um to Joe Biggs here uh this crybaby
[__] apparently he was crying in the
courtroom and he was begging the judge
to let him see his daughter and all this
[__] what a [__] what a [__]
um oh please please and then I guess
when the judge left the courtroom he's
like Trump won or whatever and then he
shows up on Alex Jones's show
from federal lockup now this is a person
who's supposed to be persecuted mind you
but he's doing a [__] live interview
on implications
no you were prosecuted [__] for crimes
that you committed against our
government I don't know and they gave
you a terrorist enhancement so that
makes you a terrorist too and they're
letting a terrorist call from prison to
do an interview with Alex Jones
it's crazy ass [__] now this is real now
I want to probably got my views than all
of us too oh well you know
he's gonna get another one here he's
gonna get another one here here's Joe
Biggs on the phone with Alex Jones this
is there's some wild [__] how he's
crying and wine and crying let's listen
oh I know he'll pardon this I believe
that with all my heart you know the
thing is is hopefully getting him uh you
know
for him to be able to get into the
position where he can at least be I
think on the ballot to run right because
once you have one minute remaining okay
so if anyone doesn't know he's calling
from federal lockup and when you're in
federal lockup you only have a certain
amount of minutes that you can talk per
period and then a certain amount of
minutes you can talk per month and you
get afforded that and then you can make
a phone call from a [__] you're
sitting on a bucket and you got are
either that or you're standing and it's
like there's a [__] Payphone is what
you're talking on and every other
disgusting [__] in lockup has
been has been talking on that [__]
that phone a lot of guys will put like a
sock over it and [__] or a shirt because
they don't how do you know so much about
this I don't I this is not all from Law
and Order it's not it's not it's not
it's not like I have experience with
this or anything but let me tell you
something so what happens is is it'll
announce you it'll announce that you're
that you're a federal inmate
or that you're in lock up when you know
if anyone's called you from jail which
I'm sure plenty of the audiences that
people from jail call them
um yeah you're you know your degenerate
liberals why wouldn't you but anyways it
announces you and then it tells you how
many minutes you have left on the call
because there's a certain amount of
minutes you can talk at a time so that's
what's happening on this call but listen
listen to how he whines after the minute
an interference right it's election
interference if they start trying to go
after him once he's on there I have to
understand that the legalities of that
but I do believe that Donald J Trump
will pardon us that he should we didn't
do anything you know we're we're his
supporters we went there like he asked
and things went wrong that day and
that's sad and that's well there's no
doubt there's another satisfied you
notice you notice Alex gonna cut him off
he's like whoa whoa whoa whoa easy easy
on the easy on the whole we went there
that day not the Wii I I didn't go there
there was no we it was the demons the
demons took over my body
[__] right the gay frogs took
over my body and the demons were inside
of me and that's what led me to be your
January 6 cubits but but it's really
[__] weird that again Alex Jones has
probably turned evidence on Joe Biggs
he's probably turned to evidence on you
or at least the proud boys and oat
Keepers and Donald Trump in general some
way and well I mean how the hell did he
stay out of this even his co-host and
his and his videographer that day were
afforded some some privileges in in when
they pled guilty to misdemeanors
um and then after certain prison time
but let's see how Alex tries to cut him
off here and put him straight they were
all patsies that day Joe you got to come
back on anytime you want on the
broadcast any time you can get on 11 A.M
to 3 P.M weekdays Sundays or we can
always tape we love you people should go
to freejoebigs.com and donate to support
yourself
hit me up always with the [__]
Griffin with these [__] isn't
it unbelievable would you like Studio
what is that a hundred million dollar
Studio well I mean you know you know
that's that's what happens when you sell
boner pills and and muscle fake muscle
supplements I mean that's what happens
that's what we should get into honestly
I should start selling boner pills and
fake muscle supplements for uh bonehead
of the week yeah that's right yeah boner
of the week I mean bone end of the week
so there's there's Joe Biggs on um on
Alex Jones's show uh again this is one
of the leaders of The Proud boys who was
there on January 6 who went to try to
overthrow our government and it wasn't
like he was there and he's like you know
what Donald Trump said we should go down
there so we should go down there
literally in court they proved that
these [__] had this planned
months in advance to do this on January
6th why hasn't the thought got through
in his head like okay why didn't he
pardon us already what because he can't
why is it like to come because he can't
say it that way because there's one
thing Joe Biggs and these proud boys and
and like Alex Jones and these others
know is that they can't speak ill of
Donald Trump because if there is a
chance that he could pardon them if they
say you love him now then it's possible
that they won't pardon him win that
possibility arises which it never will
but I mean you know that's up to us the
voters to make sure that that [__] never
happens if you listen if there's no
better reason to make sure that Joe
Biggs stays in prison is to go vote
against the Republican nominee whoever
the [__] it is it's going to be Trump
but whoever is the Republican nominee
for the next three four five six times
you gotta go vote against them like and
I I know that like God damn Tony that's
[__] dark but hey Americans vote
against [__] man oh man you talk about
mobilizing a vote they've got a good
chunk of time too big is any over 15
years or something he got 17 years which
isn't nearly enough for that [__]
domestic terrorist I mean he tried to
over throw the government do you have
any idea so so if you if you get like a
black dude poor black dude not not a
member of any kind of you know cult or
anything like that and he gets caught
with drugs and a gun oh my God they'll
give him a dirty 30 and a heartbeat and
for anyone he doesn't know what a dirty
dirty is they give you 20 years and then
they give you 10 years probation they
call that a dirty 30 because you were
owned by the bop and and the justice
department for 30 [__] years it's 30
years that you do with them because
likely that you won't get much good time
and you're not going to get much knocked
off of your 10 years of paper but Joe
Biggs was afforded a privilege of having
17 years get the [__] out of here with
this nonsense 17 years the prosecutors
were asking for 33 years with the
terrorist enhancement now the judge did
give the terrorist enhancement so this
guy isn't going to go to some [__]
mushy-ass Federal Camp which most
federal camps aren't mushy some of them
some of them not but let's face it this
guy is going to end up in a medium or
medium high Joe Biggs is going to have a
hell of a life
um trying to continue his white
supremacy in prison uh I feel like it's
just long enough to let him know how
[__] serious uh right you know
everything he did was and well in a
medium high or a medium prison it's
going to be hard to keep all your good
time too you're gonna have to do some
you're gonna have to do some wild [__]
to stay alive and to survive in a medium
or a medium high so you're gonna do some
[__] that you don't want to do in a
normal basis and you're gonna you're
gonna get a lot of your good time taken
away speaking of good time did you see
all the Nazis down in Florida oh my
[__] God okay so the best part about
this is okay I'm gonna show you a
picture really quick of these Nazis on
the overpass these are the same ones
that showed up at drag shows in Ohio to
to shout right wasn't the drag queens
with the swastikas you mean yeah well
they are in Nazi drag yes you know
what's funny is uh who was it someone
said
um oh oh yeah it was Anthony cumia do
you know Anthony Kumi is that [__]
[__] so no yesterday yeah he's he's a
washed up radio host
um Opie and Anthony he's a racist he's
oh I remember Opie and Anthony that's
Anthony that's Anthony cumia really yeah
he's a wife they were big around here on
WAAF yeah yeah he and he's a racist and
a [__] anti-semite he's he's a
[__] Nazi himself and he was he was
on Twitter he's like and I'll show it to
you he's like huh these are fake Nazis
these are feds if I've ever seen them
I'm like you're who dresses up enough he
impersonators out there you know all
those Nazi impersonators he was talking
about how they were all dressed up in
the same uniform I'm like what what on
what [__] planet were you in the
1930s and 1940s in history class all the
Nazis dressed up in Nazi uniform what
the hell are you talking about hence the
word uniform right that's [__] weird
man but but kumia and the right wing
think this guy is a Fed oh yeah
what situation couldn't he blend into I
would use him as a fan every day right
exactly well I mean you know this guy
this guy went above and beyond to get
into character here
um look at this guy you know not only is
he uh tatted from head you look so happy
too they're always so happy these nights
yeah I mean you know they're loving life
you know hating hating everyone but the
the few white guys that are loud um in
their compound or whatever the hell it
is it looks like somebody rung really
Rudy giuliani's head like above his head
and that's what like dripped onto the
nothing's face
only this guy is supposed to be a Fed
which is laughable uh but I want to show
you
um
let me show you this Anthony cumia tweet
uh since since you uh since I hearkened
you back to Anthony and Opie and Anthony
is it Opie and Anthony or Anthony and
Opie which one no it was Opie and
Anthony yeah Opie was always first
that's right because Anthony sucks and
he still sucks he's still horrible he's
still alive that was a long time ago huh
yeah he's still horrible he used to have
whip it out Wednesdays really did he
delete that tweet you little [__] I
think he deleted the tweet
oh no no he didn't no he didn't okay I I
have to I take that back he is a [__]
but he did not delete this tweet here's
Anthony he says this is blatantly fake
these are fake Nazis they act like just
like lib and Tifa I'm not sure what the
hell that means all dressed up the same
and over-the-top swastika flag and isn't
even a real Nazi flag what the [__] are
you talking about man he's like whoa
whoa whoa I know me some Nazis I hang
out with Nazis and they got the real
Flags haven't you lost the plot anytime
you have to take the Twitter to defend
Nazis I'm sorry yeah you know it happens
it happens here is uh and he goes on to
say the um the mask and the chanting if
you believe these are Nazis you're an
imbecile he's like look man and here's
what I said I want to know the real ones
I got videos in my phone I could show
you the real one area all the real Nazis
are here hanging out with me okay and
and he's like they're all hanging out at
my crib they're not down there in
Florida we just did a roll call
everybody's here
there's no way that those are the real
Nazis they're all here with me what a
[__] idiot Anthony Kumi is but I want
to show you a video
um because apparently if no one uh knows
this uh Rhonda santis doesn't think he's
a Nazi at least he projects that he
doesn't think he's in Nazi
but the neo-nazis
there's a problem with meatball they
think he's a Nazi listen to this
yeah
huh White Power white power white we're
off around to Santa's that's kind of I
don't know does that does it actually
really matter if you're a Nazi if the
Nazis think you're a Nazi yeah well
that's again it's kind of like the old
the old saying if you're sitting at a if
there's a Nazi sitting at a table and
there's 10 people eating and conversing
with that Nazi having dinner with that
Nazi there's 11 Nazis at the table okay
all right it's not hard to understand
this is not these are not hard things to
grasp and when the right wing when the
right Rings like all those guys are feds
I'm like I'm actually super excited you
said that because most of America is not
going to believe that [__] that a bunch
of [__] feds got dressed up to go to
go make you look bad get the [__] out of
here man just because it makes you look
bad doesn't it no less right well and
this was on an overpass where where's
this over pass in in in in relation to
this like is is our overhead overpaid
like federally protected land like
like [__] over
I don't know it's like is that the only
spot nobody's crazy enough to stop at to
give them [__] or something I don't
understand you know that's all that's
the only place I stand well I think it's
because there's a lot of traffic you
know on the overpass and and and it's it
is like public so like this is like a
public sidewalk the unfortunate part is
if you look at some of the imagery and
let me see if I can find uh one of these
videos where they're standing on the
overpass uh oh you're better than in
front of the dildo shop I guess well you
know
I don't I don't know I don't know
there's a lot of dildos here look at
this look at all the dildos here
um you know this guy this guy's got on
tape I forget his name but this
[__] is on caught on tape
calling people all kinds of anti-Semitic
names and thrown around racial epithets
towards uh Jewish people but you see the
fence behind him on the overpass that's
the most disappointing thing that
there's a [__] fence that they can't
jump off the overpass there that's the
only thing I'm upset about what what how
else can they hang their signs right
I want them to lean way over attach that
sign way over the Orvis to attach that
sign
um but you know what's funny is the guy
the guy who you know the guy in charge
here uh that's lore Loomer we don't
really want to talk
uh where that guy right here this bald
[__] see that [__] right
there
see him his name is yeah I've seen him
before somewhere he's the one that had
the bullhorn at the the Nazi rallies at
the dragon where's that Ohio or
something yeah yeah he was yelling he
was yelling Republican talking points
out of his out of his bullhorn
Republican policy points and everyone's
like Tony why do you call these
Republican Nazis I'm like because the
Nazis show up and yell their policy
points and their policies towards the
lgbtq community in drag queens like why
why would I not think they're
Republicans and Republicans well you
have to understand even the Nazis relied
on a lot more people than just actually
Nazi party Affiliates when they were
doing their deeds and doing their dirty
work and people to run the trains and a
lot of other a lot of other things that
they're relied on people that weren't
out there calling themselves part of the
Nazis party but actually helped these
people assist in their terrorism and in
their death you know and just everything
else they were a part of well this is
gonna if you're if you if if you don't
like Nazis which I know you don't you're
gonna love this next video that I'm
gonna show you because this is the
leader of these Nazis this is his name
is his name is Christopher I believe
Christopher uh poholes and this is him
in his car doing a little video it's a
it's a it's an intimate moment he's
crying Brian the reason why he's crying
because his wife keeps having sex with
all kinds of men in the neighborhood I'm
not [__] them listen to this it's
from like
fun flirty text to like nasty in a
couple days so I know what's happening
and I'm not don't and I don't it's not
even like
look
I don't care about my wife she can [__]
and be with any dudes you want
what they so this guy's just got more
problems than just his fascism uh
apparently the guys you know just good
Christians
[Laughter]
oh
the chances who used to be a quiet
aquatic uh yeah right an altar boy yeah
hey I was an altar board what the hell
you got against a former author boys
nothing but the priest though
oh [__] me oh okay
um
it's a shitty transition if I've ever
had one
oh God damn okay and we're off YouTube
[__] we got a half an hour left to go
this is gonna be rough uh I forgot where
I was gonna go with it now
[Laughter]
let's get this back on track
um
[Music]
let's see I had another video I wanted
to show you but I [__] forgot
the altar boy talk got me off track here
oh have you seen this picture have you
seen this picture of the huckabees uh
down in Arkansas in this the socabees
yeah and the socabees here's the here's
the Huckabee family here I don't know
who this guy uh is in the middle but
everyone has been talking Jesus what did
Mighty eat everything
well this guy in the no this guy in the
middle here look at this guy oh my god I
didn't even see that I went right to
Mike's stomach
uh I mean okay I don't I don't know you
know they're always uh you know I I
listen listen if you wanna if you want
to smuggle some footballs into the game
that's fine
that's fine if you don't want to have to
pay to buy a couple footballs to have
them signed on the field that's what you
do nobody will have a question
listen listen I'm not saying this guy
needs gender affirming surgery or if
he's had gender affirming surgery but
Jesus A lot of people are like oh Tony
you're body shaming and I'm like yeah
but you know what the thing is is that
if any any other [__] person showed
up in a photo like this the right wing
would act like this person is is a is a
demon right they would act like he's a
demon so why shouldn't we do it and have
a little that's what happens when the
photographer says all right pump up your
chest for the picture stickers
stick your chest out
put it back put it back put it back oh
son of a [__] I don't even so what do
they they're Razorback fans I'm assuming
well yeah they're they're in Arkansas
you know so they're going to be
Razorbacks that'll happen that'll happen
um apparently they're not
um at least some of them are not fans of
brawls uh but you know who's counting
here
um now who's that on the right is that
Sarah's husband uh well he looks kind of
doofy so I would would take a good sense
in the political realm
um well I mean he's the he's the first
lady of Arkansas I mean the first
husband of Arkansas you know you know
Sarah Sarah has lost a lot of weight
recently I don't know if they're trying
to starve around or what's going on
um but you know it is what it is a lot
of people are talking about this picture
this weekend because of the um
this guy needs a man's ear you guys
remember no I see no reason why anybody
would bring that picture up at all I
mean do you remember the man's ear on um
on Seinfeld on Seinfeld you never want
Seinfeld
I'm not like a religious I can name that
it's not like okay that's season three
episode 42 on that one the manzier the
bro that that the episode where Kramer
and Frank Costanza invent a bra for men
oh [__] man you've never won Seinfeld
then I don't believe that you've ever
watched it if you don't know
I think he I think he's lying to you
folks I don't I don't think he's
actually one seinville I don't think
Brian here knows anything about Seinfeld
I do a mean Kramer so do you remember me
all right let's let's hear it let's see
no I gotta pop into a door that's how I
do it
here's here's the thing we're gonna hold
you to it too you need to do a social
media video where you do Kramer that's
all I'm saying
I promise I
was at his stand up there's gonna be
thousands of people thousands of people
who see this and they're going to hold
you too that yes you need to do that or
I could just like pretend I'm sitting on
a giant wallet for your whole show oh
yeah does that help is that how no that
was George with the giant one I know who
it was I'm just saying that shows
another Kramer you know that George sat
on a giant wall but you don't remember
the man's ear
oh I don't know stop watching after
season like Elaine's dancing and stuff
like that I remember right so you so you
you how long ago is this this is like 43
years ago 43 God damn
laughs
speaking of old here's uh judge Weinbach
oh my God this Monday is getting crazy
and crazier
um here's judge Weinbach
um and just see if you can tell the
difference here between what she thinks
and what she believes maybe let's see if
we can Spot the Difference this first
one is going to be from 2016. this other
one's from like last [__] week first
ones from her beauty cannot have a
country led by a president subject to
ongoing criminal investigations but whoa
whoa whoa hey easy on the anti-trump
talk there lady
do you notice that she doesn't like
Trump now did you see that that's kind
of weird it's almost like it's almost
like they don't care when they're on
camera saying one thing right well let's
let's see if she changes her mind
potential indictment and never-ending
hearings the RICO statue that's just
theater that's just a bunch of theater
in the midst of uh politics and a legal
thing okay so you know like we like to
mock them right but they make it so
[__] easy like we don't even get to
really mock them we just show a clip of
them saying one thing and then a clip of
them next yeah yeah they were like well
literally no commentary
we can't even we can't even have fun
here like what the [__] man at least
give me some opportunity to really slam
dunk you oh here's the next one here's
Sean Hannity surely he doesn't do the
same thing it couldn't be that he did
the same thing let's listen Hillary
Clinton could be sworn into office while
still being under investigation from the
FBI which would then put this country
into a major constitutional crisis it
seems like you like the FBI then he was
just the investigation not even
indictments right right he's like FBI
wink we like FBI I mean you know when
they're when they're investigating a
Clinton we hate it when they're
investigating our orange Mussolini Jesus
this is definitely going to be a really
long investigation right right
so let's see how he feels I'm sure he
feels the exact same way now this will
be nothing other than a show indictment
to cover their overtly political
never-ending persecution of any and all
things Donald J Trump
okay wait a second he seems to have
changed his mind now a little bit
sounded like yeah just a touch it feels
like it's almost the opposite of what he
was saying before although I am happy we
made it through that whole Sean Hannity
clip without one mouth whistle from him
if he sounds like the Gopher from Winnie
the Pooh one more time I'm gonna lose my
mind
shut the hell up
oh [__] all right do you do a good
Tucker Carlson because here goes Tucker
I'm sure he's not he's definitely he's
definitely not going to do the same
thing they just did surely he doesn't
look too good on the right he's not even
in picture yet he looks like [__] man
he looks like [__] this is what hate
will do to you but let's watch he's
under FBI investigation less than two
weeks before the presidential election
holy smokes yes Donald Trump is a flawed
man but he's seen a minor compared to
those of his persecutors
[Laughter]
God damn right yes he's a flawed man
holy [__] man they couldn't even say
them before and after being fired from
every major News Network
did you know he's the only one that's
been fired from all three
and they're like he's the most
successful broadcaster ever in the
history of ever ever I mean obviously
and to them you have to bankrupt three
casinos and about 40 other companies to
be the most successful businessman well
that is true so why why wouldn't they
believe then well let's see if old old L
Newt here I I thought Newt Gingrich was
dead he looks the same yeah well he
looks the same
it's like you could put like 50 years
between pictures of Newt Gingrich you
need to still look like death's door was
knocking right
come on man I thought he was dead is
Newt Gingrich still alive is that
breaking news are we breaking news here
live on the air the Newt gingers I
thought this [__] was dead I'm
not kidding you I thought he was dead
but let's listen to what the dead guy
has to say second people are about to
have a candidate who is clearly going to
be under criminal investigation for the
entire first and second year of her
presidency all these indictments are
about politics not a single one of them
is about the law
yeah none of them none of them actually
went to a grand jury and used the law
that's on the books to to bring
indictments against them because they
broke criminal law yeah no it shouldn't
be this easy
like it shouldn't be this easy to be
like look at how hypocritical and just
ridiculous you sound from one year to
the next it's just unreal well it's it's
not hard um back to the um I want to go
back to this
because some people are posting in the
chat I guess this guy in the middle
or you know I don't know I don't I you
know I shouldn't be so insensitive I
don't know what their pronouns are I
mean I know
what it appears but I you know I don't
know I just I just don't know but
apparently that is the head coach of the
the air the Arkansas and Razorbacks
that's the football coach
the what why is he stealing why is he
stealing footballs he should have plenty
maybe the last person that expect to
steal footballs would be the head coach
maybe those are the goddamn maybe those
are the goddamn game balls that he's got
I don't know the helmets
I have no idea I have no idea that's
what happens he took two helmets one for
Sarah and one for Mike that's what's
going on somebody just happened to catch
a picture before he was able to get him
out of his shirt and into the cause so
nobody could notice that's what happened
and to the what the car it might have
been three because it looked like Mike
has one under his shirt
they were going to Mike's shirt they
were they were stealing a line but what
did you say get him into their what
their cars I thought the cars that what
yeah because the cars the con the thing
you drive
the automobile
yeah okay I'm just making sure around
here we call it a car
um or a trick do you get trucks
get in the truck [__]
though we got three helmets for you
getting the truck stole three helmets
yeah they they say truck a lot in
Arkansas get the truck yeah well they've
been really not good at uh pickup trucks
down there because every country song
their dog is always falling off the back
of the damn thing yeah you think they'd
learn how to use that tailgate by now
[Laughter]
I want to show you um let's see should
we go back to the oh my God I got
ta did you see Tim Poole tweeting this
weekend and do you pay attention to that
[__] I heard he had some stupid
tweets I didn't I don't know if I
actually saw it exactly what they were
oh buckle up you got it you got a seat
belt in that car you're sitting in
You're Gonna Wanna buckle up here buddy
all right here is here is that Jesus
Christ I looked up I looked up here's
what here's what Temple said he says
this is what Democrats fear
hahaha
okay I I guess it's that we're supposed
to fear AI is that what we're supposed
to be scared of I don't know this is
real why would they keep the head the
same if they're gonna go through all
that trouble why keep the same wrinkly
face with his neck and everything what
what about his neck what about his neck
right here what is that called Olivia
Nick
oh labia Nick Donny he if any anyone's
who who is this yoke does not have a
labia neck I can guarantee him to you
that tell me that come on like if you're
like you get you could get copyright for
Camel Toe just for showing that
that is true I I may get a copyright
strike just for the camel to him on his
on his [__] chin oh my god oh Tim
Poole so he didn't just tweet this or he
tweeted several others but this is this
is you know what's funny about this
tweet more than anything is it's one or
two ways either Temple really believes
this or Temple's audience and his
listeners and his dumb [__] followers
believe this [__] it's got it can be one
way or the other like this isn't a joke
right or is it doesn't he try to portray
himself as a lefty type dude though like
I know that's a ridiculous thing to say
but isn't that how he tries to portray
himself he said he used to be I used to
be a lefty or some [__] like that which
I mean a lot of these right Wingers
claim that [__] and that's the reason
why is because they make more money
being right Wingers I told my audience
this man the way I sound the way I look
if I started saying right wing [__]
tomorrow man I I would have millions of
people lit millions of inso listen
they'd be giving me all kinds of [__]
money that's why it's so ridiculous for
them to say that they're canceled or
they're you know they're they're D
platformed or anything they conservative
people are concern uh consistently have
the most views if you look at the uh the
the platforms you know I mean they're
they're always the highest in in the
amount of views that they get the right
wing content creators right right well
and and that what the reason why is
because they Stoke outrage with lies
right I mean that's because because that
part of the country and that part of the
the universe doesn't want to know the
truth or doesn't want to cop to the
truth that's the thing that they want to
do that's not a thing that they want to
do I mean just look at look at how they
still support Joe Biggs these proud Boys
The Oath Keepers how in the [__] would
any organization
Recruit new members if their entire
leadership apparatus was federally
indicted for terrorism domestic
terrorism like it would be difficult
other than be like hey you want to be a
demand hey you want to be a domestic
terrorist
come on down you got the job for you
right right right
I mean that's literally what we're going
through here uh in this country in in
this time period this weird [__]
timeline uh that we're in I have another
video I like to show you were talking
about Christians earlier right and how
you you know unfortunately you're right
I I didn't get to show this video I'm
looking for videos that I wasn't able to
show last week
um we've showed several
of these videos from this account uh but
this is a Christian hate preacher let's
see if let's see if the the kind of
ideology that you're talking about with
these right Wingers let's see if this
person knows anything about it in in one
of uh in Pastor Shelley's sermon he said
that one of the terrorists I I mean the
protesters you know thanked him for
giving him a reason to live you know to
protect to come and fight the church
right okay well reprobates I'll give you
even a better reason to kill yourself
stop earning a lower Place in Hell with
your wicked ax you know and uh the Bible
says that if you offend a little one
it's better if a millstone were tied
around your neck
well so millstones are kind of hard to
find these days but you know uh you know
maybe a large Rock and and jump off a
bridge that that's my prayer against
reprobates and there's some pretty tall
Bridges around who's the hype man you
probably wouldn't even need to walk you
mean the one guy listening there you go
amen
you mean the one guy listening in this
guy's living room that literally looks
like it what it looks listen you got to
give him credit though you got to give
him credit he's got a see-through Podium
which for a preacher or a priest is a
big deal because you know there's no
kids hiding under there
are you are you are are you a reprobate
casting disparagement on this man of of
God is that what you're doing
um I'm just giving him credit for
letting us know that there's nobody
locked under the podium that's all
yeah so my response to that was
Christian because uh they said Christian
hate Preacher Brother Alex uh of the
here's the name of the church
sure sure Foundation Baptist Church in
Seattle Alex
brother brother Alex from the sheriff
Foundation Baptist Church oh my God
he's got me saying it already
I said Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ it's working come
[__] no she's speaking of more
um anti-christian and anti-semitic
Christian fascism white Christian
nationalism here's the king himself I
was gonna say his name I was just gonna
say you you know this this guy met with
Donald Trump with the uh the Hitler
lover
um yeah Kanye West and they they love to
have dinner Trump loves to have dinner
with white Christian nationalists these
Nazis it's not just DeSantis that the
Nazi support I love what he said I
didn't hear anything uh if they submit
it get my table not while he was there
thank you thank you Nazis they may be
Nazis but they weren't Nazis when I was
dining with them they didn't seem to
hold their Forks like Nazis hold them
Nazis have a certain way you know what
I'm talking about don't interrupt me
Brian you know what I'm talking about
Nazis have a certain way a certain way
of Holy Ghost how is that your
justification though like well because I
didn't see it right look I had my eyes
closed the whole time I didn't see and
not see anywhere and when he said Hitler
I went la la la la la la when he talked
about Hitler I didn't imagine closed
they were swollen shut I'm not
mentioning to tell you but that's why
they were shot oh my God so here's Nick
Fuentes oh well let's uh let's just take
a look here let's listen the people of
this country are Furious they don't like
my hatred no no he hey he's right he's
[__] right
oh my God he's like you know what no one
likes me no one [__] like yeah no one
likes you of course they don't you're a
[__] Nazi man no one likes not one
full one let's go let's see if he gets
let's see if he gets some more truth in
here the poor
let's see what
for the poor oh my God they don't they
don't like that and I don't know why
I don't get it
uh but I don't care because I do [__]
hate the poor and I hate poor people and
I hate poverty and I'm sick of lying
about it I'm not gonna pretend that I
don't okay I love the rich I don't I
don't have any animosity for the rich
men of America okay I want to be one
so he's like I hate the pores and I is
one was that what he's gonna say right
no right but I mean you got to give him
a little credit for not bringing race
into it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah don't don't do you
gotta say yeah we're gonna throw him a
bone that's gonna be the bone I'm gonna
throw oh wow he's managed to go this
whole time without saying the n words or
anything too anti-semitic he loves the
bone you know that yeah she don't eat
meat but she sure liked the butt he
wouldn't know though because he's an in
cell so not too many girls around him at
this time so we I don't know if he
really knows what to do with that bone
when it happens
[Laughter]
I want all my friends to be rich I want
all white people to be rich oh there it
is there it is
another three seconds
Tony's just gotta play the tape and Nick
would be a racist all right let's let's
now now that we're at the intersection
of racism and and boredom let's let's
hear it
I want to emulate them
I want to be one of them I want to be
among them
among them I don't I don't know but yeah
you know they definitely got the race in
there he definitely got the racism
like I'm hoping that was part of a like
a bigger video or is that did he just
put that clip out right wing watch
um ghost and watches uh Nick Fuentes
they do a service for all of us actually
you know what's funny is Nick Fuentes
was on telegram posting about Gabe
Sanchez's what was that that Gabe did on
Nick Fuentes was he oh yeah so Nick how
does he still post like where is he
still allowed places like Telegram and
[__] that's it that's it I mean they let
him they let him back on um
well they let him back on Twitter for a
bit and then and then one one night he
was in a Twitter space
and he was talking about Marjorie Taylor
green and how much he [__] hates
Marjorie Taylor green because ham and
Laura Loomer have a beef with Margarita
green which is delicious okay Madre
Taylor green came and spoke at one of
his little knots oh my God and then
wouldn't defend it afterwards right
listen basically when I love when there
is punching of Nazis but when Nazis are
punching Nazis um yeah right there is
nothing more that's that gets my heart
pounding and the love going the Nazis
punching their own
um that's beautiful speaking of that of
the same people like what is with like
have you noticed that Fox News is now
just using clips of crimes being
committed to like exit out of there like
just oh with music over it it's just
like you know San Francisco lootings or
whatever you know the clips they left to
play on Fox News to get all the white
people mad and stuff they're just using
those clips like you know have a good
day and then as the music's exiting them
out it's those clips playing in the
background and I'm like what like this
is just wild [__] yeah you know they're
not even talking about they're just
playing it like okay here's your
birthday is there's something to get
pissed off about for the rest of the day
to like jingle me it's like yeah right
yeah we'll be right back 79 degrees
it's like what the [__] like Jesus
Christ and one of my grandmother was so
pissed off all the time right well that
is a reason to get pissed I mean not
actually at the you know
she wasn't oh okay she was really nice
oh man I'm glad that she came on the
show today and I know I appreciate it
thank you it's been a treat
um that you uh came on honestly we were
chatting early and I totally forgot that
today was a holiday and a weekday that I
was home and we're like oh [__] I'm
apologizing I couldn't get on the show
last week because I couldn't get out of
work yeah you're like I didn't even
[__] occur to me you didn't even
[__] occur to me that today was the
day and then rejection I had just left
the house I was like you [__] so
so where where were you going where were
you going to the laundry do do some
laundry oh okay I wish it was a more
exciting story I wish I had something
better than I was doing but that's just
what I didn't have any clean didn't have
any clean underwear then no my town is
just [__] jam-packed right now
because of Labor Day I'm somewhat on the
water here so my town fills up on nice
days and it's so extra crazy at the end
of summer so it's how a holiday is the
holiday a good day to go do laundry is
it is that what you're saying no I
picked the worst day actually probably
that I could pick but that's usually
what I do I procrastinate until it's
actually worse than when I originally
thought to do it and then I do it so
it's more difficult than if I had just
done it to begin with and given myself
more time so that's how I like to roll
so what so what you're saying is what I
hear you saying is is that is that I
saved you from doing your laundry on the
worst days no it's there it's yeah okay
you prohibited me from going to pick it
up is what you did oh okay so again in a
way in a way I kind of screwed you I'll
call you in about 10-15 minutes today
all my clothes were stolen it's all
right I have no [__] drawers man I
will not be able to wear I'll be free
bowling tomorrow in a pair of pajama
pants because all my [__] [__] I
always have a blast coming out here the
last time I was on we left and it's just
I enjoy it very much the chat's great
the people in here are great the people
that follow you they watch from start to
finish so they're good people oh yeah
well you know we got we got a lot of
great audience going here and they they
don't give two [__] they they like to
get down like we like to get down uh
just the same way that dark Brandon
likes to get them I don't I don't talk
about Joe Biden but here's the clip
apparently I'm talking about Labor Day
since it is Labor day and maybe you can
give us
um your a little bit of commentary first
of all it's Labor Day what is it Labor
Day Labor
Labor Day Labor Day well I call a decent
[__] wage day is what I got decent
much decent [__] wage day but here's
here's dark Brandon uh talking about
what Trump did and what Trump didn't do
we also
also picture law
world
with a second rate infrastructure
can you believe we used to have the best
infrastructure in the world and then we
felt the number 13 in the world Rhodes
Bridges entered the whole deal 13. the
United States America 13th in the world
but guess what
guess what
the great real estate Builder the last
guy here he didn't build a damn thing
under my predecessor
infrastructure week became a punch line
on my watch infrastructure has been a
decade and it's a headline
we're investing in America and our roads
Bridges porch airports
you know Donald Trump had infrastructure
week every week and he never got it done
this guy got it done did you know that
yeah I did yeah I mean like I said I've
always said I he wasn't the person that
I was dying to vote for in my opinion it
was a lesser or two evils but he was
he's turned out to be far more
consequential of a president than I
expected him to be for what I thought I
was getting for what I was voting for to
tell you the truth he's done he's done
an amazing job he's had his moments and
it's unfortunate because I feel like
that's taken a lot away from the good
things that he's done but I the things
that he's done is still being passed so
I I can't fault him really I'd rather
have him seven days a week twice on
Sunday than than the other half
obviously right well and you know the
other the other thing about uh Joe Biden
is he just gets up and puts his shoes on
and does his [__] job just like all
the other Americans out there that are
looking to try to make a living all the
people who if they're not union members
they owe it to union members for all the
all the work conditions that we have in
this country and it's why we celebrate
this day even though we're on air here
what do you call it equal wage day Fair
wage day nice decent [__] wage day
it's a decent I just it's ironic
considering I'm making no wage today
because it's a holiday well you know
yeah
no wage day here at the Tony Michaels
podcast on
decent [__] wage day oh [__]
um hey you know what you know what I I
told I want to recant my um from earlier
I may I may have over exaggerated the
the Tim pool tweet
um I it may have been a fake I think
this is probably
this is probably this is probably the
real one
um this seems
this seems more appropriate
um this one
Jesus Christ I think this is the
appropriate AI I think this is the
actual AI image that that Tim Poole
meant to post I mean this is how I know
AI is getting too smart already this
looks real to me this looks totally real
to me
that'll be on the next Trump flag and
it's definitely you'll you'll see that
on a [__] pickup truck in no time
this is definitely what Democrats fear
as well
um this image right here this is a
it never never fails are we at zero days
talking about dildos or porn or
something
I think our counter is at zero days now
um foreign
laughs
oh my God I am glad that you joined us
today to watch that I appreciate it so I
do I really do turn your eyes out like
that and as much fun as we have it it's
extremely important it is it really is
you know it's important for us to get
together and laugh at Donald Trump
holding two big dildos and the in the
right wing like yeah that's what we want
they're terrified they're terrified of
us no we're not we're not terrified of
you uh so I appreciate it Ryan thanks
for thanks for coming on everyone and
don't go anywhere Brian's gonna leave
but I got a few announcements for you I
appreciate it Brian we'll talk to you
thank you buddy later guys have a good
one we'll see you soon everybody Boston
Brian go file boss and Brian everywhere
I'm sure we've got his link tree that we
can post I really wasn't expecting uh to
have him here today and I you know I
wasn't expecting the sparklers to show
up I didn't I didn't know I guess Hal um
through the sparklers uh on the show
here so thanks to Hal Sparks and welcome
to all the sparklers sparklers are
always welcome here at the Tony Michaels
podcast so is Brian I'm glad to have you
guys here on this Labor Day I know it's
a holiday
uh we didn't have Gabe Sanchez but we
got the surprise visit from Boston Brian
so thank you guys for for hanging out
for two full hours as you do every
single Monday even though it's a holiday
thanks for doing that make sure make
sure to go to the Tony michaels.com
let's see Tony michaels.com subscribe to
the YouTube channel
subscribe to the YouTube channel don't
forget to do that also and I want to
give a shout out again to everyone who
bought me a shot last night and this
morning about everyone rounds uh to be
honest with you so if you go to the Tony
michaels.com just hit the Subscribe
button at the top uh you can subscribe
for free any of the changes that we make
like links for The Daily Show it'll be
emailed to you and also you can buy me a
shot you can listen to the Sunday rant
it's right there the link is still there
from yesterday if you want to watch me
punch Nazis for about an hour uh if you
want to get in on the venmo chat it's
there too so thank you uh for the venmo
chats today uh to Pace
let's see if we got any more shots just
to make sure before I leave you know
we're getting to the to the top of the
hour here
um but also also don't forget to go over
to the Discord most people are crazy
over there uh hang out on the Discord
it's where the the chat party never
stops it doesn't end over there on
Discord uh so go there and it did so I
want to thank all the people who bought
shots who support us on patreon and
support Gabe and go follow Gabe's
Channel if you want to find Gabe's
Channel just go on down to the podcast
links and it's right here Gabe's YouTube
channel that link is on the Tony
michaels.com go follow him over there
he's got over 8 000. so yesterday during
his patreon
we made it public and a lot of people
joined in on mine and I threw into his
hour so I I do an hour rant on Sundays
if you guys don't know on patreon just
go to the Tony michaels.com click on the
patreon link you guys can go make sure
you watch every single Sunday rant there
sometimes we make it public we have the
last few weeks and I threw into game
show Gabe joined me at the end of the
show yesterday on Sunday and then he
threw into his show
um and you guys got him over 8 000
subscribers so he's over eight thousand
now he's on his way to ten so get over
there go to the Tony michaels.com check
out all the links but go to Gabe's
YouTube channel subscribe to his YouTube
channel don't forget uh to go to the
Discord you're definitely going to want
to go to the Discord now don't forget
that and and when you go to the Discord
it's not hard now but you're going to
want to verify so you stay in the
Discord and they give you access to the
Discord you just got to click the check
mark button just go to the Welcome
Center once you go into the Discord I
just put the link in the chat and you
guys can go over there you can hang out
you can show your pictures
um I've actually been posting pictures
of some of my morning walks because the
sunrises have been beautiful uh I've
shared that I shared a weight bench that
I built a couple years ago they got all
kinds of crazy stuff going on in there
stuff you make pictures you take
um just if you're a foodie there's a
foodie Channel there's all kinds of
stuff over there make sure you also when
you go to the Tony michaels.com you also
follow the up wire the up wire we're
we're on there give Jim a shout out
Jim's our moderator there thanks Jim for
holding the fort down over the up wire
go to the upwire.com you'll find that
channel there as well go follow us on
Facebook download every single episode
on Apple Spotify and Google on another
way you can support the show and we
appreciate your support because without
it we couldn't keep going we have to
keep going uh here on the Tony Michaels
podcast you can follow us on Twitch it's
free go to twitch.tv Tony Michaels and
here's the thing if you have an Amazon
account you can link it to your Twitch
account that's right you can link it to
your Twitch account and we get a couple
extra bucks so here's how you do that
just go to the Tony michaels.com scroll
up here there's a there's a link here it
says link Amazon and twitch it gives you
certain directions on how to do that and
it gives us monetary support with your
Amazon Prime account and it doesn't cost
you an extra single nickel and you got
to renew it every month so if you've
done that if you linked it to don't
forget to go resub over there on Twitch
thank you very much same time same place
tomorrow I promise Gabe Sanchez is going
to be here so don't miss out Texas Paul
we got Fred Wellman tomorrow as well
same time same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon
I'm a hard-working man living a hard
work in life I got my hard-working kids
and my hard work give me life I like to
take it easy but I know why I can't
budge doing it all those fat guys
telling off the fudge if you eat fudge
once then you're a traitor in Mars
driving me that aren't about fat people
none of my songs are about fat people I
I don't know even where you get okay
well here's another one here's another
one Lord we got so
many words
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the problem
I'm not pro fat I'm not pro skinny
people always try to put you in a box
like what body type are you you know in
favor of work such strong hours
[Music]
where it's those bad guys eating chips
and through those chips they control the
global economy workers of the world rise
up and Unite with a combine strength now
we can win the fight
if you act together well I don't see why
we can't defeat our enemy people of a
certain BMI hey if you're five foot
three well that's a bad start but I also
need to get your weight so I can
calculate the next part no the song is
not just about fat people it's way
bigger than fat people which is must be
huge
[Music]
I'm off